hey man this is your first time
no man i i've been doing a zombie extra
work on this show since
day one first season man my first time
was your first time on this show my
first time being
extra at all ever kind of nervous oh wow
okay man hey man
i'm sorry about you you'll be all right
man it's okay man it's not that hard man
you'll be all right
i'm me personally dude i'm looking for
that lunge bump though
what's what's a lunge bomb oh that's uh
like if you um you get featured
if you lunge at somebody and then you
get a bump in your pay and if you really
lucky man
they blow your head off that's straight
bank right there that's
director gather round jerry hey jerry i
had a thought man about the first scene
that y'all not now stan
oh steve it's steve okay okay i'm gonna
need somebody to lunge at the fence
you think you can handle it yeah uh
yeah it's his first dado he's kind of
nervous man he's kind of nervous it's
his first day okay so the director's
gonna yell
action mac's gonna come by and then
you're just gonna lunge into the fence
like
you you want me to say grah oh say
whatever it's crazy
okay all right cool man hey you know hey
that's cool hey you know i got a lot
more experience man you can just use me
i've been here
day one first season so and okay cool
all right that's fine you're gonna go
with him all right good for you man good
for you
guys no don't do you don't have to say
god do whatever you want to do man
that's the lunch box that is the lunge
bump man you got it
you got it on your first date ever
being an extra ever you got it man good
for you
and action
what the hell was that cut oh man i
would be more than happy to fill in man
i'd be more than happy to step in mac
just remember when you're coming through
the factory that hey like your mind is
still in the car
i mean you all got to pick people based
on qualifications man you can't just be
picking random
good notes but maybe what i was doing
sort of superseded that agreed
yeah we were just discussing that
absolutely it supersedes it yeah but uh
let's do one that just
seeds it okay just same level we're
going again straight away okay right
away okay
he's not doing a good job at it you're
doing great though man opportunity
knocks gonna answer the door man
action
[Music]
cuts i'll be more than happy to step in
at any time
you want me to i'd be more than happy to
do it just a certain sense of urgency is
all we're looking for
clock's ticking you've got survivors to
find right can't tell you off with
something real segment
this dude right here is not doing what a
zombie does this dude was literally on
our last take
waving his hand up in the air like this
jerry making beaker sounds he sound like
beaker
from the muppets y'all thank you that's
great just a ticking clock on this is
all we're looking for because there are
survivors is what we're after okay
i found the ambivalence in there the
ambivalence is
art it's gorgeous and we love it but
there are zombies so if we could just
pick up the pace just a hair that'd be
great well straight away please right
away
jerry we're not doing night of the
living muppets are we we are not because
the beaker is not a zombie you have any
notes
yeah don't be a beaker quiet please
action
i'm gonna eat your brains zombie god
no he actually just said the word zombie
come on man you ever hear a zombie say
the word zombie before no you haven't i
don't think so
you know what get rid of this guy thank
you that's what i'm talking about y'all
i'm sorry dawg but you terrible at this
man
do your thing hey man no he talked about
him no he's talking about him because he
said zombies thank you steve
no you want me to leave hey man i've
been up here staggering around here for
three and a half years and i've been
startling extras
left and right when do i get the start
of the lead huh one more for safety
straight away
action
hey what do we do if we have to go to
the bathroom
we like it i love it genius moving on
thank god